[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh frank joins us he's the net studio
host on yes uh he's also siriusxm
nba radio the starting lineup he uh
contributes to around the horde and
pardon the interruption
uh let me start with the poll question
the team that's gonna kick themselves
the most after last night the jazz
or the sixers it's gonna be the sixers
they were up 26
the jazz would be second and i would put
milwaukee third on that list though even
though milwaukee played
you know a nets team that hardened was
clearly not himself
it's still kevin durant so you're losing
to a guy having a tremendous performance
and we all know that he's capable of it
i mean come on if you're a utah you're
showing up for work in your own building
and kawhi leonard's not going to play
and then if you're philadelphia up 26
how about the way they played down the
stretch of that game i mean it's
the numbers are off the charts think
about it dan the fourth quarter of the
last two games
embiid is one for ten and tobias harris
is over five and ben simmons has not
attempted a shot in the fourth quarter
of games four and five that's remarkable
do you have to take him off the floor
now late in games i think you do i think
once
the hawks get to that fourth foul i
think you got to take them out if i were
atlanta i'm not going to intentionally
foul to get to my fifth foul
but once i get four i don't care which
quarter it's in
i'm gonna foul him because you could
tell it's clearly in his head and it's
affecting
the sixers and the fact that they're
gonna be on the road
ben simmons i give him credit for this
at least he faced the music last night
he was in front of the media and to the
media's credit they asked him a lot of
questions about his shooting
and specifically his free throw shooting
and he stood there and he answered all
the questions and b
did not meet with the media but simmons
has to do something this is now becoming
it's one thing for it to happen during
the regular season occasionally in the
playoffs
somebody had a great stat dan that he's
already missed
more free throws in 10 playoff games i
think it's 45
than steve nash missed in his entire
career in the playoffs he missed 44.
this guy's already missed 45 in the
playoffs it's hard to believe and i know
doc rivers is trying to say the right
thing about
ben simmons and he's a unique player and
he's a great player and
but i can't ha you're not a superstar in
a liability you can't be both walking on
the floor in the same game
yeah i also think you know shaq
struggled with free throws but you never
had the feeling
that shaq was nervous about going to the
free throw line and i think and i think
the same thing is true of giannis and
tata kubo who's not a good free throw
shooter
giannis isn't worried in those moments
but when you're not taking a single shot
in the fourth quarter of the last two
games
when your team blew an 18-point lead and
a 25-point lead or a 26-point lead
what does that tell you to me it's like
he's i don't want to use the word afraid
but it seems like he's afraid
to step up to the free throw line and
take those shots that has got to be a
major concern but you're right about doc
doc's doing the right thing he's going
to stand by his player
but this is up to ben simmons he has to
figure this out somehow
all right so do you have the clippers
figured out now
because i don't you know in the dallas
series i didn't
even in the bubble last year i still
didn't have them figured out
now you don't have kawhi uh woad says
kawhi is probably doubtful for games six
and seven if there is a seven but
so now it's it's paul george again and
then uh
you know that's supporting cast yeah you
know i've been hearing it's a
significant
they worry that it's a significant acl
injury so who knows when we'll see kawhi
leonard
i give paul george a lot of credit you
know he gets mocked a lot
and he did not play well in the bubble i
don't like the way the things that he
said about doc rivers especially after
doc rivers had gotten fired
but he's had a couple of big time
performances to go on the road this was
all about the utah jazz they have to win
that game i have not had
the clippers figured out i will say this
when marcus morris plays well
they seem to play well he's a tough guy
he knocks down big time shots
utah completely fell apart last night
they're shooting in the second half i
think they were three for 24
on threes i don't enjoy at times
watching them play when they're moving
the ball around they look good
but there are times when they're just
settling for long deep
three-pointers and it backfired on them
big time in the second half
frank isola he covers the nets their
studio host on yes and a contributor to
around the horn pardon the interruption
uh let's uh focus in on your nets what
do you expect tonight
i'll be interested to see how many
minutes kevin durant plays in the first
half you know he won 48
obviously in the last game i i think
he's going to come out at some point
in the first half of this game if it's a
10-point game in the fourth quarter does
steve nash decide to maybe pull the plug
at some point
and say you know what let's just rest up
for game seven i do think that harden
will knock down a couple of shots he
just
i give him credit for being out there
for 46 minutes he just didn't have it he
was never cutting to the basket
eight of his 10 shots were threes which
told you he was just settling
i don't think you're going to get 49
points from kevin durant i think you
will get a big time response
from the milwaukee bucks i expect them
to win this game i think we're going to
get a game seven which will be a great
moment
i just think durant playing 48 and james
harden playing 46
i think that's going to catch up to the
nets tonight i
i scratch my i was yelling at the tv the
the last game because of what the bucks
did and did not do
i know i gave harden out there you don't
take advantage of him make him run make
him guard somebody
the greek freak had chances he had james
harden guarding him
i know any and and he doesn't take it to
the hoop he doesn't want to get fouled
he doesn't want to go to the free throw
line
i mean that is that's a that's a flawed
logic here
you know during crunch time with one of
the great players a two-time
mvp crazy yeah and i and i thought the
nets did a great job
of attacking brook lopez they kept
getting him in pick and rolls and he
could not guard whether it was jeff
green
whether it was blake griffin or kevin
durant turned the corner
kevin durant kept beating him to the rim
so the nets were attacking brook lopez
then
and meanwhile the bucks were not
attacking james harden you're so right
late in that game
when the game durant had finally missed
the shot it was just under two minutes
to go
and giannis had the ball and he's
shooting a fadeaway
jumper along the baseline it's like come
on i love the guy he's a
he's a terrific guy he's a self-made
player but
some of the decisions that he makes late
in games it just drives you nuts and i
also thought a little thing too
late in the game when they were down two
i'm talking about milwaukee
with under 25 seconds to go i'm going
for i'm going for the three there
because i'm thinking if we tie the game
durant will probably hit a shot at the
end of regulation anyway and if we have
to go five more minutes
kevin durant's gonna end up with 60
points forget about 49 points
i would have gone for the three i get it
chris middleton made a good play
driving into the lane and then giannis
fumbled the ball but you know what
go for the win at that point because at
that point you would have been lucky to
get out of there with a victory
and i i've still and i mentioned this
yesterday i've been
watching the nba for over 50 years
i don't understand how the best player
on the floor
doesn't face a double team to get the
ball out of his hands
not not once did milwaukee truly double
team durant to say
you're not beating us if if green beats
us or
somebody else beats us then that's fine
you're not beating us
i go back to when jordan hit the shot
against the utah jazz
i was watching it the other day i'm i'm
yelling and i know what the end result
is
they didn't run anybody at michael
jordan i
i don't understand this logic frank i
know and if you go back to i think we
were probably at the game when indiana
played
the lakers it was either a game three or
four in indiana
and when shaq fouled out kobe took over
and they had mark
you know larry bird had mark jackson
guarding kobe and they never ran a
double team at him to get the ball out
of his hands it was so frustrating
to watch from a milwaukee buck
standpoint and also put giannis on him
at some point you watch the nfl they put
the best cornerback on the best wide
receiver for crying out loud
to try to stop him in the fourth i get
it you don't want to get giannis and
foul trouble
early in the game i think in the fourth
quarter either entered the fourth with
two
or three foul so he's not going to foul
out at that point you got to put him on
kevin durant
get the ball out of durant's hands and
make guys like joe harris who couldn't
make a shot
make him beat you i get it jeff green
had probably the game of his life
but you know it's a little bit different
when you're taking those shots in a one
two point game as opposed to when your
team is down 15
and you're wide open in shooting i just
mentioned lebron james had comments
saying hey i told everybody that
we were going to have all these injuries
here do we have all these injuries or
just injuries to marquee players
and anthony davis is not in shape that's
why he got hurt
kawhi has been bothered by that knee for
a long long time
james harden wasn't in shape this year
so when
when you had a sprained ankle by lebron
doesn't have anything to do with your
conditioning kyrie had a sprained ankle
nothing to do with your conditioning
uh so you know lebron you kind of want
it both ways hey can you limit the uh
regular season here but they're not
they're not offering to give up 25
of their pay so while i understand it
was a quick turnaround
you had guys who weren't in shape to
start the season
and these players aren't going to give
any money back
yeah and i think kawhi was at 52 53
games this season
so that was not a wear and tear
situation same thing with kyrie irving
he was in the low 50s for games played
so
same thing with embiid and b played 51
games this season then has the torn
meniscus so
it's not like only jokic played 72 games
everyone else
you know was in the 50s or the 60s and
if you're lebron you're a big part of
the union
you guys agreed to do it to your point
they want it both ways
so you you wanted to make all the money
you could
and now after all these guys are getting
hurt and there have been a ton of guys
that have missed playoff games you're
saying well maybe we should have cut it
back
to me that's up to the nba and the union
i think they blew it i think they should
have played a 60 game season
i think right now we should be in the
nba finals i think the season i mean dan
we're not out of the second round
i think about where we are on the
calendar when i look up and i'm thinking
oh man i'm going to be working july 4th
weekend
which i'm used to doing covering free
agency not like being at games it's
going to be a little nutty
yeah it's yeah i mean even throwing
embiid he's never really been in shape
i mean i give him credit he's playing uh
yeah well
you know the meniscus tear but but a lot
of these guys
uh you know donovan mitchell that
sprained ankle is still there
like that's not conditioning i i think
it's just yeah so that's that's why when
i hear this with lebron do i want the
nba
decided because of injuries you know
who's the healthiest
no but you know when kd went down
or magic got hurt in the finals against
the pistons
i mean it it happens it's unfortunate
klay thompson goes down
you don't like it but that's part of the
game and i think too
you know i think back in the day the old
school guys if they had
it's one thing like magic had the
hamstring entry couldn't play and harden
obviously he had to miss some games
because of the hamstring injury and
kyrie irving obviously can't play now
but i do think there used to be if guys
had were banged up a little bit
they just played and they didn't want
you to know about it now guys
they they play hurt and if they have a
bad game they make sure their post-game
press conference asks you about i always
say this about patrick hewitt
patrick had bad knees obviously if you
asked patrick ewing about his injury or
his knees he would give you the death
stare you're like
don't go down that road talking about my
body how i'm banged up and i'm hurt
i think guys now can't wait to tell you
well the reason i didn't play well
is because i'm dealing with this
situation i think i think there's a
little of that at play
as well but you also with gambling don't
we have to know this now now
it's full disclosure that i i need to
know what's going on with
you know the fact that tom brady had
knee surgery in the off season
and was not on the injury report due to
his name during
during the regular season like that's
not supposed to happen in this
you know world of gambling but i think a
lot of it too is gamesmanship they don't
want you to know that so
sure the nets i thought it was
gamesmanship with them when they
announced that
james harden had been upgraded from out
to questionable i thought that was
something they would just want
wanted to mess with the milwaukee bucks
but if you look at heart and script
we're talking about guys that don't play
you look at his career numbers of games
played if he's healthy
he's out there but you're 100 right and
i love heart i love the way he plays
he showed up out of shape in houston so
forget about the you know forcing his
way out he was never in shape and you
have to think that
probably impacted his hamstring somehow
but if he can
he'll be out there and he showed that
the other night with 46 minutes
have fun tonight frank thanks for
joining us thanks dan i'll see you guys
frank isola the
net studio host on yes and uh sirius xm
nba radio the starting lineup
and he contributes to around the horn
and pardon the interruption cup